[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà voilà c'était c'était juste
une petite démonstration avec quelques
pas de danse tunisienne populaire sur
une musique de notre cher ami artiste la
sardine alors très bien à la fin de 2ème
siècle tunis capitale a connu plusieurs
phénomènes de danses populaires citadine
évidemment la danse populaire existait
bien avant que ça et parmi les
phénomènes les plus connus est le bourg
et quand on dit rebours on dise vous
faire je vous explique la danse du bourg
était une danse vulgarité place et
c'était une danse populaire improvisé un
vrai phénomène c'est adam née dans les
milieux ouvriers de la ville de tunis à
la fin du iième siècle a pris le travail
les ouvriers aux flammes
d'ailleurs le mot sophie vient
directement de mon français ouvriers ces
ouvriers avaient l'habitude de se réunir
dans les cafés des lieux exclusivement
masculin et l'or reprenait en dansant le
travail quotidien
le terrassement le portage le piochage
dallage et c'est toujours sous
l'assistance d'un public d'ouvriers
masculin qui participe bien évidemment
avec l'écrit
les sifflements les claquements des
mains etc alors il dansait chantait
parler de l'amour de la vie de travail
de leur sexualité dans un espace
ouvertement sexuel dans un environnement
très masculin où il ya beaucoup d'audace
beaucoup de liberté physique est atteint
selon le discours moralistes de la
bourgeoisie tunisienne la vulgarité
parmi les les phénomènes les moins
connus il ya sadeghi par exemple dans
d'autres régions
saadé oui il a un autre nom algérie ce
saadaoui était pratiquée par des des
femmes à l'intérieur mais à l'extérieur
si un homme décide de faire ça dit il
doit s'habiller en femme et il doit
surtout cacher le visage
il ya aussi un délit ça vient d'eux en
dé la zone des lacets hameau d'origine
turque qui veut dire en français cellule
en arabe zen
c'était un répertoire de danses de
chants et de musique des prisonniers il
ya aussi par exemple le goupe b ça vient
d'orbea c'était les danses et des
prostituées vous savez que tunis
capitale depuis 2 527 jusqu'à l'arrivée
des français on avait presque 14
quartiers réservés à la prostitution
dans la ville aujourd'hui on n'a qu'un
seul malheureusement
alors ce nombre infini de phénomènes de
danse montre que la société tunisienne
n'avait pas de problème avec la danse
née avec les danseurs lien avec les
danseuses verts sachant que les danseurs
ça n'existait pas vraiment des danseuses
dans l'espace public dans l'espace
commun c'est à partir des années 30 40
jusqu'à les années 50 60
et quand il ya eu cette vague des
danseuses d'artistes femmes qui sont
venues de l'intérieur du pays et se sont
installés à tunis capitale comme par
exemple ça les a avec la musique le
chant et tout ça il ya eu à zinal aziz
amami azoh mbi bavaria et a beaucoup
d'écoles de danse féminine cette période
précise e set il peut qu'en fait on a
commencé à détruire les frontières entre
le monde des femmes éléments des hommes
entre la danse féminine annonce
masculine d'ailleurs il ya eu des formes
croisé par exemple ça débit qui était
intense des femmes
elle a été récupérée par les danseuses
las les cavaliers le bourg même
aujourd'hui dans le box est une danse
mixte c'est grâce à qui c'est grâce à la
mld ya les joueurs de mazout qui anime
et nos fêtes en fait ils ont récupéré la
danse dudule bourg ils ont enlevé un
petit peu les scènes obscènes et surtout
ils ont fait participer les femmes donc
jusqu'à les années 60 c'est à dire à
juste après la dépendance bourguiba
voulu faire de la danse amitié il fait
appel à un grand homme à dinard baby le
premier danseurs folkloriques
professionnels pour créer la troupe
nationale populaire et bien sûr dans la
troupe il y aura un bal et avec des
danseurs et nous on n'avait pas des
traditions de balle et donc il a fallu
inviter des formateurs des professeurs
de danse classique russe est belle et
bulgares d'ailleurs si vous remarquez
dans les danses de la troupe national
des arts populaires
vous voyez des formes classiques
par des bras des grands jetés du grand
écart des pirouettes même et monte sur
les pointes est même sûr si on les met
pas un thème sur les pointes
donc c'était un peu déformé comme danse
donc bourguiba a beaucoup aimé les
danseurs il a même fait des
interventions il a obligé par exemple
les danseurs de la troupe a apporté les
colons blancs pour cacher les jambes
bon en imitant un petit peu le modèle
soviétique à cette époque hamadi la bbc
aussi de de faire ce qu'il appelle lui
dafri faut un vip c'est à dire enlever
l'aspect sexuel voire obscène de nos
danses et surtout il a tracé du nouveau
les frontières moi j'appelle ça des
fausses frontières des frontières entre
le monde des femmes et les membres des
hommes et s'en rendre compte qu'il a
détruit un troisième monte qui se passe
entre les deux
kiki qui hélas est sûre ça je travaille
aujourd'hui c'est sur cet univers qui
existe entre le monde des femmes et les
mandéens donc la troupe national des
arts populaires
il était très présente elle a joué un
rôle très important
elle était présente dans les cérémonies
officielles dans à la télé dans les
manifestations culturelles politiques
diplomatiques en tunisie à l'étranger
donc elle a joué un rôle d'un d'un d'un
musée ambulant d'un vrai conservatoire
conserver c'est c'est protéger ses
classes et ses stocks et c'est
finalement rendre tout ce qui est
d'ordre vivant statique figé finalement
c'est tuer le vivant c'est aussi pour le
laury's et c'est aussi faire de notre
danse nos danses une carte postale
présenter à un public de touristes donc
peut-être à cause de ça que le public
tunisien le tunisien ne se sont plus
denses et danse il est et prend une
distance par rapport à c'est dans cela
mais je pense que c'était légitime mais
ce qui n'est pas normal
de transformer cette distance par
rapport à la danse on n'a pas un regard
mais pris un rouge est dans une position
contre la danse et les danseurs
peut-être aussi six ans fut un petit peu
dans l'histoire
vous savez dans les années 90 il ya eu
les premiers mouvements de danse
contemporaine
il ya eu des artistes et chorégraphes
qui sont venus avec une nouvelle
expérience occidentale et sont
complètement
ils sont installés ils ont installé
cette expérience ils ont complètement
rompu avec le local avec nos danses
locales d'être aussi ça et ça explique
ça il ya aussi une autre explication
dans les années 90 il ya une montée de
conservatisme 4 à cause de ça mais la
question qui se pose que je pose
aujourd'hui c'est comment faire comment
faire pour retrouver votre amour votre
admiration et votre respect surtout pour
la danse merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]